hey let's talk about spawn so I should
talk about it I told him I told him to
surprise me and yeah I guess you're
thinking like oh I gotta do like a big
reaction for get a spawn what the fuck
dude that's really my only address
fucking spawn I remember there was so
much hype for that movie like was there
yeah I uh ever at least at least in high
school I don't know about yours I mean
when I was in high school but I did that
but see a lot of this was like very
beginning of Internet so I'm not talking
about like internet hype I miss talking
about at my school I was like oh my god
this fucking C spawn and then like a
couple days later like what was our
internet of the day which was just our
classmates like kind of coming in and
like telling us what it was about and
and and it's just the reviews were
trickling into class it was just like
yeah a couple girls briegel it was but a
lot of it was just I am what I saw it I
really because I think it was after
Batman Forever and I kind of drank the
kool-aid cuz I am like the huge man
crush on Jim Carrey like every little
boy did and when insisted Batman Forever
was Oh as soon as I came out I was like
totally drank the cool head of a Batman
is better than both is it you could have
to carry just shit into a fuckin in a
river sit I did it's amazing
this man had ever uh cuz yeah I was like
like mommy little kid was like yeah but
even I was like you know be nice to see
something at you kinda dark again and
spawn it what really cool uh you know
especially the design of these uh of
spawn of the clown and everything you
are the trailer helped the trinket has
all those trailers that it tricked you
yes I'm really here looks better and
then when you actually sit through the
movie it's like yeah and it's uh what
sucks is that the Gothic people I
brought up in the review but the canopy
did Walking Dead Evil Dead IV that that
phenomenal team is that candy or I I
don't know I don't know all that no one
was like Greg Nicotero yeah that's all I
wanted yeah then uh that team though
that's amazing that they're phenomenal
and they do this movie and you know
because now they're talked about doing
another film which is a good idea the
other films not very good but you know
it's not gonna look as good as that
movie at least the the clown and spawn
are not gonna look as good okay you
practical effects yes I don't know ends
distinguish Gigi's talking about the
practical effects the CG is like I mean
you just see so you're like okay
shame on sorry I thought I could just
see like the the fanboys now like just
hands ready like shame everywhere I'm
like practically Oh cuz like the CGI
effects saw it a suck are the only thing
I effects will definitely be better in
the new one the only thing you get I
give a little bit of pass on is the cape
because it's like how do you do that
cave without going CG and granted it
clearly doesn't look like it's there
buddy
it looks like the comic so it's like
okay all right um and the fight thing is
someone I'm and the cake to me was the
least offensive effect yeah cuz that
Lisa kind of look what a casual deal but
yeah yeah I'm I gotta hits a cartoon but
there really was no other way to do you
could have hand animated it damn doing
it I got I'm not convinced it would have
been it would have been like Roger
Rabbit that when I look at either I
don't know how you would have done that
as a practical effect so I yeah I get
the kaepa pass but I mean the biggest
one I didn't notice until I was actually
editing is when he's looking at this
little he's in the graveyard he's
looking at something that's supposed to
be glowing and they actually cropped the
top when they're moving with it I
couldn't believe that why you see see
shining and then just it stops at this
plant line you know and I was just like
oh my god like even I don't make that
mistake and I think a lot of effects
mistakes well I meant that sort of
satanic devil Beelzebub creature whoever
that's asking spawn to build the army
for him you have can be if you have
these guys
and you will cause aging I okay someone
got me a fam got me a few spawns spawn
comics because I actually I seen bits of
spawn by other like actually read up or
anything so I start kind of looking
through them and of course not reading
it in order uh but you know it's just
sort of glancing through and everything
you know trying to follow it's like the
artworks amazing but it's very hard to
bring to life I mean like you look at
that clown and it's like it's amazing
what they did cuz they even had like the
crazy teeth or there's like a million in
one little line and stuff and it's
amazing what they did and I finally saw
with the devil looks like and the devil
really does not transfer well into real
life cuz he's supposed to look kind of
cartoony and they tried to do it with
that CG abomination and I'm with you all
the times you could use these guys these
phenomena measures and Evelyn they're
masters at doing that bill think of the
Evil Dead to in the Danites you know
yeah and the closets like they're
masters of doing that and it is fuckin
the oh it's not even like there were
like video game like there were cd-rom
games with better CGI no and then it's
fun I mean it was just in Barris what
and what they did to cuz again I mean
now that I do you know very cheapo
effects but still effects uh I'm
catching on to how they do a lot of
stuff like they have all these low
spawns whatever are doing the weird
things that they do clearly didn't have
the rendering time so they just took it
with the glitches and stuff and then
like to make it look like it was more
three-dimensional they take a layer of
sponsor and they would just get it
closer to the screen but it wasn't shot
that way so they look really pixely and
really blurry up here when they're
flying by and it just looks like funny
bad it's like homemade like bad cd-rom
bad um and it looks like a Nintendo 64
character yeah um and the fight thing
too is that you're talking about the
trailer the trailer for this movie is
really good uh yeah I was psyched from
the Train yeah and though I watch it and
I just remember
like what they showed if the movie
followed the same order and direction
that the trailer did it would have been
fine because it's like II you know he
used to be an assassin but he died you
know shows a die nobody went to hell but
he was given a second chance now one
lone teacher will trade him and bring
him back to the world and it's like it's
that I go in origin Island you're
working that's when he's like good but
like Merlin doesn't teach him until like
the last third and even then it's one
trick suddenly he's a Jedi Master after
that clearly they must have cutted or
something at least 20 minutes with a
lightsaber and a flying wiffle ball yeah
that's what we need well but that is bad
when I'm the new hope gives you like
more than like a new hope and force
awakens put together would give you more
then you know I hear something soon
looks kind of figuring that like you
know I always kind of thought he's
teaching them a little bit more on the
side there's something like that you
know like when they're on the ship of
the million Falcon and stuff like that
like showing I'm only known it from
about three days no not much but you
know just a little bit this is literally
a trick one trick and then there's no
there's no force like that's always the
stack excuse it's the force which I'm
okay I want you to accept that and I
just got apply to all the movies but
yeah I don't know what it is I don't
know if it's like just um if it's like a
cliche finger movie thing or a guy thing
whatever I love training montages I love
training scenes I love all that stuff so
you get so excited on it I love that
shit I love it too David as I do
it's like finally went through the whole
movie to get to the scene and here we
are with a great fucking actor that guy
you know the guy that I just call him
early cuz I forget okay coins yeah a
bike he's phenomenal if he played
Sherlock Holmes he played Marley he's
all these uh great characters and here
he is a he's about to do the trick on me
you know why we're called because having
because Excalibur is an amazing movie
you should see it yes no if you if you
didn't grow up in the 80s and you missed
it go watch it but because it is the
same character like it just feels like
that Merlin character from Excalibur
gets having no sense of humor until the
end he gets a little bit since he humour
but even though he's like all right yep
oh I stopped Catco it's like haha my
prep like and he tries so hard to sell
it but that intro where it's just like
and now I will begin with a giant plop
dump a long long time ago in a galaxy
far far away a bunch of stuff happened
here we're going to show you in the
credits it just my guess is that cuz
even reading the comic Michael is just
that was a last-minute insert because
people like oh yeah the studio notes
probably said people will be confused
yeah so they throw it even more stuff to
make it even more come yeah the I do it
is I ended up just being more confused
yeah cuz I was like what the hell is all
this um and when they uh cuz I'm looking
through a comic and it's not very
coherent like it jumps around a lot like
two different time periods even
different characters and stuff like oh
those are killer they want you there
yeah or me yeah and it looked like the
guy um created it you know definitely
had like some input on this movie it
wasn't like they just took away yet
knowing but like he definitely had a
little input um but how much it's
sounding like map too much but it was
definitely there and I am kind of
wondering if like you know maybe he
thought well I'll just do this like the
comic wicked this is how storytelling
mind works it works like a comic where
you can jump around and there's so many
stories and can do these and stuff like
that uh and different timeline than cuz
that's another thing with comics they
don't usually go start to finish there
so because you create other characters
where they come from well you have to go
back to the past in this scene with this
character when they met that character
remember that five issues ago and that's
comics in a movie you gotta follow it
and this should be like the easiest
thing to follow guy dies goes to hell
give second-chance breaks looses I don't
want to fight for hell and then they try
to get him back I mean that's basically
it so why is that hard to follow why do
they make it so complicated and crazy um
I'm just said that John Leguizamo is
stuck in that goddamn suit giving you
his all you've been violated carry bad
clearly giving it as all trying to be
funny trying to be entertaining at times
he kind of is oh I do remember that the
reviews at the time and even even back
at school ever is like that fuckin clown
man that clown was awesome but that it
was like what about the rest of me
what's the rest of it is I always took
it that seems like a guy who he has a
person didn't know if he had talent cuz
he was just in so many bad things and it
seemed like he was trying to Johnny Depp
but where he's trying to go through such
crazy kids movie by Johnny Depp I get
before Johnny Depp Johnny Depp did no
joke Depp was giant upping it before he
was Johnny Depp again or tomato stuff
like that but that was a slow process I
think of Ed Wood I think of Edward
Scissorhands and it's know it was pretty
quickly since he did movies he's like
I'm kooky I'm Edward Scissorhands I'm
looking like what we consider the
quintessential Johnny Depp roles as
opposed Pirates of the Caribbean thing
like before that you could still see him
doing normal shit hmm like because you
had Edward Scissorhands and you had Ed
Wood and you would like Sleepy Hollow
it's basically just the three Burton
films now we just do another Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas which would have
been okay so this one this way I I don't
know I still feel like John Leguizamo
was throwing it like from the get-go
what are you doing to do I'm where he
tried to do a sketch show that
everybody's really excited for it just
didn't work um you know we kind of
wanted to work that really didn't work
um and I think from there that always
and they tried those horrible comedies
like the pests and stuff and I think he
kind of said you know instead of just
going pure comedy I'm gonna go again how
what Deb is doing where it's kind of
like half funny but have kind of weird
and edgy and kind of odd and that seems
to for the most part work for him um but
yeah
Elano versatile bamboo sadly but uh but
I've opened up to like you know he's a
legitimately good actor like he could
even in the happening way SSL was
terrible lines he's giving it his all
and he's actually like man if what you
said makes sense I would really buy this
um I still believed in is Luigi Amalia
from the oven my my brother my father my
son mother my daughter my sister but dog
Oh so yeah you know can we talk about
Martin Sheen's assistant there her
outfit educate talk about Martin Chi for
a second every time we talk suit on
right yeah check it like he wants to be
patent or okay I would like to think
that this is the Donald Trump version of
his president on the west wing like this
is a bizarro version world of the west
wing president he has a pictures of
explosions it's scorpions and spiders as
I trust this guy so used to that
southern accent he has at the hair I'm
shouting I'm just like the fuck is this
yeah and they're like just that weird
time where it was like I mean I'll give
him this it's like he realizes this is
garbage
ya know but like I'm gonna do what I
want well you're saying about the
assassin yeah there was that weird time
where as kind of lies you know with on a
top and golden idol very worked but like
everybody was trying to be on the top uh
everybody was trying to be like you know
the Sochi what I got it it's not just
the sexiest okay see like in Goldeneye
it works because the Bond films have
their own silly reality yeah um there is
just something about this where I'm just
like when people talk about the
silliness of like just throwing some
chicken with a giant cleavage at
supposed to fight like for some reason
this one in particular month man this is
the poster child for that he doesn't
bother me an x-men much didn't but like
there are other like comic books where
it doesn't bother me but there is just
something about her where I'm just like
this is so impractical why would an
assassin just have an outfit like this
and it looked like he was made out of
like licorice Twizzlers what black
licorice I'm like wait where'd you get
this outfit what does this have to do
with anything like it just I don't know
it was one of the rare times were like
one of those like silly sexy like
assassin outfits stood out as I'm like
that's just fucking ridiculous there is
it you know what it is because all the
other times they did it there was an
extra something to him like you know you
talk about x-men you know mystique she's
a mutant she's covered in blue she can
shape-shift you can turn all these
things um on attack she's horny analogy
shooting goes good oh it was yeah with
her legs and stuff like that you know
there's all these weird things I think
throw it out incorporated it's about
this just felt like and just put some
broad MacLean region air you know yeah
you're some guys then give her some God
dark lipstick there you go this is like
there was no thought put into it at all
where's like at least you can see a love
of character design because I'm like I I
normally actually don't have a problem
with it
well those I don't get involved in all
of that you know cuz for one thing for
me I'm just like as a guy I'm like you
look at like Thor and half these
superheroes abut I feel really
inadequate guys let's put on how many
hundred times where there are times when
it is so blatant and so fucking
obnoxious and I'm like wow I can't
defend this you know is it lazy and like
this is what those things are like this
is just fucking lazy it's blatant but
it's boring - yeah it's also boring yeah
I know I think that's the thing is that
she's like every stock badass assassin
woman a tight outfit with a gun and
there's like nothing else interesting
about her here's the thing when you do
that sort of thing like like in a Soul
Calibur game or something or in a comic
book movie if someone has like a sexy
outfit that's supposed to look badass I
should sit there I'd be like badass yeah
if I laugh when they come out which is
exactly what I did in spawn I just was
like fuck then you failed yeah I feel
like I should I should be wrapped up
into it enough that I'm just like
alright rockin what sound that the
Marvel movies do you know very well is
that they you know cuz I kept saying
every time under all these movies was
coming out out in the you know days when
the MCU was just starting I was like
okay well you did whole but you can't do
Thor that's got
be ridiculous and stuff and they really
incorporate those badass okay but what
you're doing Captain America now you can
with the little ways you can't do they
incorporated it they were so smart okay
and how many worked it in even in it was
still silly but this something is silly
is bam beta Robin I didn't really
question Poison Ivy's outfit because it
seems part of her person she's part of
that world
Catwoman like so even in the in like the
DC Universe it doesn't really bother me
but but occasion there's this one where
it's like this just bugged me it's just
like wow you just didn't even it's just
like you could just read the studio
notes put some babe in a skin-tight
outfit like it's like just no thought
probably that's just it nothing else
just hurts giant exclamation for hips
which yeah I'm with you if you're gonna
do that the superhero is everything you
know it's I get it it's gonna be an
exaggeration what we all want to be and
with the men is going to be super huge
muscles like beyond impractical with the
women it's going to be super super sleek
but somehow super strong at the same
time you know it is it says okay they
can pick up a pen but it's like you get
comic books what is the ones that it's
the Wizard of Oz effect if you make me
forget that that's probably the real
reason behind it then you've done your
job
yeah buddy look but if I can see it's
like seeing the man behind the curtain
if I can just see the studio note that
says tits like and that's the only
reason that's there that that bothers me
like you know or come up with a better
costume designer or something it wasn't
just the fact that it was like all boo
Bheema cleavage it's just it was such a
ridiculous looking outfit on times like
this isn't even good costume design it's
just silly
this looks like she's wrapped in
Twizzlers um you know that that guy uh
the guy who plays spawn who I guess I'm
not super shocked he didn't go anywhere
because like I'm sure he's like acting
and he's acting fine but you know it's I
really feel like you need a guy to do
this role as like really gonna leave an
impact on you because there's so little
that the rest of movie can do outside of
the makeup can we can we
say it out loud this just needed Wesley
Snipes because blade like when I saw
blade on my us this is what's fun with
my cut is done right that would be so
awesome I stole a baby it's over Stephen
Dorff fuck oh you're so wrong so wrong
you're so much fun i stevedore visitor
but i could that character just these
people are food there are food let me do
my entire performance just looking at
blade and the other like higher up
vampires just getting een no no is got
yeah master your door oh god I just how
did it like when that one good like a
dude who we're gonna be good how do
these fuckers take over anything these
are the lamest villains in a comic book
to be fair outside of like fucking
Superman for to be fair they're not very
good vampires I think we don't damage it
others me because the blade is awesome
and he should they have a villain that's
equally awesome and instead we got
Stephen Dorff so he doesn't mean a
stephen tour if I know you watch these
but I don't hate you as a person Stephen
Dorff I hate your fucking character um
but uh try to think what else oh and
then like the ending words like again
they're just throwing all this shit you
all this craziness and then it's like it
just kept going yeah and there's like I
thought like surprise endings and you
kind of don't even know we're supposed
to be super happy when it'll get here
don't make sense yeah you can tell like
where the budget cuts were having is
forever epic climax in the living room
next to a fireplace
I'm like really like they said the
whatever the clown when he turns into a
gremlin who of course doesn't talk you
just got raka that's what happens we
turn into a big monster and they go into
hell you ain't any two Midnight's goodie
man I love how it's like they go he's
like trying to destroy spawned
everything and it's like uh only I can
destroy spawn I guess and he's trying to
destroy him and it's like there's a
million
these other spawns they should take two
seconds to kill this guy he Lance is an
armed spawn yeah so are the rest of
these millions of people fucking gallop
boom he's gone and yet somehow it's like
they can't get this guy and even this
giant devil I just feel like wrong and
that's it and a spawn it's making a
David Goyer your script look confident
oh gosh I keep it right it's funny
because I could see certain stupid
things and didn't be like man haven't
had his fingerprints on why that's right
he goes from oh but yeah actually the
more research I did David Boyer
pericardium the horror research I was
doing at David Goyer was learning that
sketch I'm Callie yeah he's not sounding
too good
oh you mean it annoys you how he thinks
he's way better than his audience always
doesn't have the talent to back it up
and I start yeah I start looking at the
times like he made fun of his audience
and stuff and I'm like dude how many of
you are virgins Wow
yes as well you're acting like you're
cooler than your audience and you're
really not in fact when you do that you
become so less cool um and yes because
that means even the people that you are
like trying to claim are lower than you
think less of you yeah think about that
like that's a vicious circle um so I
don't know maybe cuz I seen some
interviews too and he seems he sees
pretentious but he seems you know nicer
fine whatever it's tough but then like I
read all this other stuff I'm like I
don't care if he had any tail yeah if
it's just know that that's a thing I
don't care if he's a jackass like that's
the most celebrities are jackasses we're
fucking jacket wear such jackasses I
also think we're talentless so I have no
illusions about that but he like he just
doesn't have any talent that's what
bothers me I'm like he can be a jackass
all he wants I'm like well if you might
be a good superhero man we all forgive
you and play it's about as close as we
got yeah which even then looking at
everybody's a dirt net I'm like yeah
third string co-writer whatever like
this much like Dark City I think he's
just hired to dumb it
because Nolan's too smart no that's all
realizing - is that like we played
watching it again even though I really
liked it uh it's all in BO it just
sounds also a blade real fun yeah sorry
just going off ideas going oh well just
we'll just say that this is a
combination blade and my vehicle say if
they juice they're kind of related
African American hero dark natural yeah
very very Oh do kind of have issues one
is obviously way better one one was the
like apology for the other one yeah
maybe that's it's just um um but not I
know what you're saying it's watching
you you can tell like this is an edge
you like the stories actually okay it
was like a funny stories just paid I
number yeah but no surprises but the
actual writing I'm like these are not
good line actually the only surprises
that anybody would want to sleep with
Stephen Dorff
when blades moms like oh yeah I'm like
ah but apart from that no surprises yeah
you got you know that's story yeah the
story's not very good it just are the
initial set it's a best paint-by-numbers
and the funny thing is the writing I'm
like if you take those lines out of
context and hand them to lesser actors
hand that line to Hayden Christensen in
like and George Lucas directing and we'd
be laughing and saying this is one of
the most worse written film ever is the
directing and Leslie fucking snot you
see that really makes that movie it's
Molly agador not a big audience all the
actors to the Crandon really good yeah
there was Isaac yeah your is even Dermot
but for what he had to do I thought I
did great
it's not it you know what it is it's
it's the writing see I could just blank
day McGorry I just I don't like the
characters just not I you could have
gotten anybody to play that character
and so long as the lines and attitude
are what they were it's just this punk
like if I guess he really wouldn't be
millennial because of that yeah what we
would call a millennial now like
gangster a Gaga feel god hipster vampire
with ease face no come on II
that's how you do it yeah I swear
there's one scene where he likes to wear
blade stabs him and he like like the
blood or whatever cuz he's buggin out
and he like holds on to this already
literally does he whole fuckin
performance but I want it I love it but
uh we're trying to buzz oh how did he
take over all up without us on our city
bond at the fucking tail talking about
not had a security detail
the vampire leaders and this Punk walks
in with a dozen or so of his Hot Topic
friends and there's like well I guess we
surrendered fuck is up with that can we
get back to the superior film please
spawn clearly I've ever talked about
Captain America Civil War no we haven't
seen that yet but it's well just already
say it's good cuz everyone else's um I
will reserve judgment till I see it done
it okay I I know what to talk about the
last thing we talked about a spawn
because I was tempted whether or not to
bring this up I was just like yeah cuz
one of the reasons I saw this movie cuz
I'm getting really pan but I was like oh
well here's a good review
Roger Ebert and somewhere down the line
he hit like even though I see and I
still love it stuff but he hit like this
mark or something where it's like if it
looked really good
he thought that or in the recommendation
and I guess at the time he felt to be
fair parts of this do look very good so
music
he looked how he'll what he felt like
this was an inspiring
Debray love the haunting the antibonding
of the haunting but even then he said
look this movie's crap but it just looks
humble in the house was so dr. Dennis
three-and-a-half stock but a lot of
critics did too visual feast for the
students know but but that's the thing
that he was being visually if it looks
visually good it's like thousand
Australia he was really going into you
know how great he'll look and then is
one of the lame as hell's as
and it struck me as a little kid who is
very impressed with new flashy toys and
I feel like CGI in particular because he
was one of the few critics that while
some critics were like this looks fake
and screw this and he was on the ones
that he constantly did a lot of reviews
like now these are good the effects are
good and he was defending George Lucas's
vision in the Phantom Menace review and
gets gonna do any your a but I mean he's
well he struck me and I think the blade
review was a perfect demonstration of
that of just like you've just kind of
falling in love with like the new toys
like a baby's fine what I say is I
played oh wait no way man I forgot what
it's reviewable oh you liked it be
though yeah so I I don't know I just
always got that in prison and it is
something about him that kind of bummed
me cuz there are times I'm like there's
no way this is like a three and a half
star movie like if you want to give it
to for the effects go ahead but I but
that's the thing about critics that I
have to remind people because the word
said this about this er how could you
guys say this about this I'm like all my
job is to tell you what I thought of the
movie myself so you know once it's your
job to go and figure out what a critics
biases or likes and dislikes are and
what turns them on and what turns them
off and it's your job to kind of put
that together in your head and be like
oh well nothing else was said a bunch of
things about this and I don't like that
but he does so I'm wondering if maybe
like this movie isn't for me and once I
figured that out about Ebert like when I
kind of would get a review that he's
like basically was saying in more or
less words its eye candy I'd be like all
right
I'm not interested and generally I've
seen a lot of those films like on TV or
something years later generally was the
right call my dad not maybe they liked
it that's fine but like it's that's on
the audience to try to like or the
readership to try to figure out you know
what it is that we like and stuff
because that's all we could tell you is
if we liked it or not so and if you're
like why I disagree fine
then figure out next time like well
would I agree with them or not based on
what they've said in the past I'm not
going to sit here and like
I know there were some people just like
I just kept sending letters to Eber
because this time like don't like dead
now so really don't do it no but let me
know excellent we're almost out of
battery here so we should probably wrap
up here okay but but yeah IM just like
that's just wasting your time
cuz i'm not gonna sit here like well I'm
gonna change the movies I enjoy because
of you know I would enjoy what the fuck
I want
yeah and say babe you want we going on
and I'd be like something like if you
just like it just like it you know it's
fun yeah extra points in what do you say
like that I like it I'm like good for
you yeah right like it I'm gonna send a
hit squad but yeah I gotta say so yeah
that's her thoughts on uh spawns em wait
wait uh go see played yeah it's tough
old skip spawn still have fun oh you
know what youtube the best scenes would
John Leguizamo and then go see play yeah
and maybe him like busting the ballroom
doing some flips
but yeah aside from that you can pretty
much skip it so uh that's Ben will talk
to you later later some other fuckers
are always trying to watch spawn instead
of blade lying from spawn you've been
violated Gary bad ok asking